the bachelors coming for us to fantasies
to you but what will it bring we've got
the answers it's time for roses and
roses a happy new year everyone I'm
Lauren Zima and it's 2019 I hope that
you celebrated on New Year's Eve I did
with all my friends please drink
responsibly new year new start new you
or is it the same you I don't know
either way I like you and I like myself
so you guys what we are getting is a new
season of The Bachelor it is less than a
week away
Oh drama let's talk about it I have not
dated a virgin since I was 12
: under what season of The Bachelor
season 23 begins January 7th on ABC and
we are here to break down everything you
can expect because if there's one thing
you care about does Eve embark on this
new chapter of your life this new year
full of hope possibility options for
change moments to grow juries to embark
on and abilities to reinvent redirect
and recommit if there's one thing you
care about amongst all that it's the
bachelor
okay let's begin I lost my notes here
they are 2019 off to a strong start whoa
drink every time we question if we're
ready for this new year hmm
are you guys ready oh god I got hair in
my mouth it's already starting as I was
saying are you guys ready for the new
year do you make new year's resolutions
I don't really but maybe I will if you
guys have good ideas
I would love someone could come up with
a new year's resolution for me please
submit it in the comments tell me what
your new year's resolution is and also
what the you think I should do with
myself in this year because there's
always room for improvement a lot in
this case anyway alright everybody
things that we have to look forward to
about the new season of The Bachelor in
the new year first of all it's the same
reaction I have when my glass is empty
tears every time I look myself other you
know joint I can't accept a proposal per
the trailer we will be seeing lots of
tears from Colin's ladies and from
Colton here's what he told me about
crying on the show how much will you cry
when the moment presents me to cry I
will cry could you cry in the first
thing I could cry on the first night
another thing to look for this season
the fence jump goal turn like I'm on the
other side what
I'm right here waiting for you wherever
you go whatever you do I will be right
I was gonna rewrite that but the words
are so good holy cold and jumping that
fence it's the moment everybody can't
stop talking about from the trailer
here's what Chris Harrison said about it
there were things that led to me having
to talk to him that forced the jump so I
would say 75% my fault all I can think
about is remember home improvement with
Tim Allen and he had the neighbor what
the [ __ ] was his neighbor's name Wilson
yeah Thank You JC and he was always like
read by the fence wait like oh I tell
you it was an amazing thing I'll never
forget it's like what's on the other
side of that anyway next thing to look
forward to the contestants in dog years
Lucy 70 not long before 2018 ended Chris
Harrison introduced them all officially
via Facebook live and told me which ones
to look out for there's Hannah B and
then there's a Kaelyn who was Miss North
Carolina so once Miss Alabama won Smith
North Carolina they were in the same
pageant together there there was Palace
crossed relationships had pageant drama
had and it's in it spills over into the
pages of The Bachelor next up the show
covering new ground new year new stuff
yes Chris promised me that Colton and a
contestant named Kaylin will have a
conversation that is so emotional and so
serious he didn't even really want to
joke about it and that it is truly
unlike anything the show has done before
I will say this on a serious note with
Kaylin is that she brings out a story a
personal story that is one of the most
emotional kind of revealing
conversations we've ever had on the show
we were all very much taken aback and so
was Colton and then that kind of prompts
things in Colton's life that's my thing
I do want to introduce a clip now
there it is maybe you can make it come
forth from my hands it's not an effect
we can do what is Photoshop do we use it
I don't know the number two thing we can
look forward to by the new season of The
Bachelor the live three our premiere 3
our primetime event oh I'm already
exhausted you know why because the skin
Bachelor does this to me every year the
Golden Globes are the night before
January 6 so please watch me because
I'll be covering them and I'm excited
and then the bachelor premieres January
7th it happens to me every year you guys
it's a period of time where I don't
sleep I forget to take my makeup off I'm
not even sure if the same makeup is
still the makeup on my face I question
everything about Who I am deeply and
almost base-level from my inner core
because I just don't stop so I look
forward to that let me go live on
Instagram or something take you guys
behind the scenes of the depths of the
period I'll be experiencing it's about
40 million hours of no sleep but the
bachelor live 3 hour premiere
should be fun I am excited honestly
because you know what why not why not
why not number one Wow I wrote down for
the number one thing to look forward to
by The Bachelor my own New Year's
resolutions crap I screwed up the number
in my notes this is so on point this is
so on brand this is so on trend for 2019
already 2019 is Jessup agonda we're
already
can you get this Laurens New Year's
resolutions that's on there please
ignore my nails I haven't gotten them
done in 2019 who's at the time so my New
Year's resolutions include one try new
types of rows a to drink last four more
rows a three drink rows a with all of
you honestly guys so excited for 2019 to
start it's gonna be great isn't it life
is about not looking at the cup half
empty but half full and you know how you
look at it half full you keep it half
full always thank you so much for
watching in 2018 cannot wait to watch
the new season of The Bachelor with all
of you please tell me your new year's
resolutions and inspirations in the
comments below
so that we can all rise above and do
better together or something so that we
can all jump all of life's fences JC
since I'm so terrible at coming up with
new year's resolutions in 2019 what's
yours
2018 was all about sowing disease so for
me 2019 is about reaping the rewards for
all the hard work for plucking the fruit
of life so to speak
wow he always has something emotional
thoughtful perfect to say and when you
pick that fruit of life I will turn it
into wine
[Music]
I think you should come in with your new
year's resolution what is it
Wow life - I'll reap what I've been
sowing in 2018 see he comes out with
this inspirational crap that noise he's
coming